afternoon castle Ridgeway
so you can start the meeting it's like
okay thank you
well welcome counselors to this meeting
of the standards committee
it's Wednesday the first of July 2020
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to YouTube and by the council's
website the meeting is also being
recorded for the purposes of the minutes
I've been advised that the livestream is
now open learning if for any reason the
public can no longer hear or see the
meeting over the livestream we will
adjourn until the connection has been
really established can I ask the
governance officer to explain the
procedure for this meeting
Thank You chair microphone should remain
me to all times unless the member has
been called on to speak by the chair
this is to minimize background noise a
member should leave their cameras
switched on
remember wishes to speak on allies to
them or during the debate please
indicate this by unmuting your
microphone and raising a hand you may
also use the chat function to type speak
voting will be done by a simple show of
hands which will indicate that the
committee is in agreement parish council
of representatives and independent
persons aren't voting members so they
won't participate in any votes if you
are disconnected from the meeting please
try to rejoin as quickly as possible you
have any technical difficulties please
contact one of the meeting facilitators
as indicated on the meeting access
details if you're about to speak the
meeting will wait for a few moments for
you to rejoin and just for clarification
today in the meeting we have the chair
councillor Armitage
councillor to act with Karen Liggett
Ridgeway house ruff and Shipman and we
have the monitoring officer Sarah stone
Berg the deputy monitoring officer
Victoria Bilson the governance manager
Nicola help and myself Amy - Clark right
if we can go to item one and the
governance officer please advise you
through being alien apologies for
absence miss chair with the secret
colleges and councillor row and also
from parish council estat Coleman and
Derek Skinner
thank you are there any more apologies
councillors who wish to submit apologies
on behalf of an absent member please
turn your microphones
done now members have indicated they
wish to speak
thank you I took two declarations of
interest if any members do have any
interest to declare can you please turn
your microphones on now sure no members
have indicated their wish to submit a
declaration of interest thank you so
move to item three minutes of the last
meeting can we agree that the minutes of
the last meeting were a true and
accurate accurate vote then please
that's carried Thank You members that's
been agreed move now to item four
emergency delegations and I would ask
Sara Sternberg my Richard officer to
give this report Thank You chair first
of all apologies I've been unable to
produce a written report for this
therefore I'm going to take you through
the delegations but I will produce a
written rule next time which will also
include their use as it became clear we
were going into lockdown
there wouldn't be member meetings for a
while we put a list of emergency
delegations together the intention was
to keep the business of the counts are
going where there were no meetings it
was initially for three months and has
been renewed until the 31st of July I
will be asking the leader to extend this
just as a backup measure for virtual
meetings the list of delegations
themselves includes a number of their
areas contracts and contracts variations
disposals of land above the key decision
level nice various licensee hearings
approvals opposes and strategies
approval of the annual governor's
statement
and the statement of accounts write-offs
of deaths above 3500 pounds six months
absence by members where there's not
attendance for six months this can be
dealt with by delegation the calendar
meeting and Constitution get change we
also covered the specific delegation to
enable environmental health to deal with
the coded regulations and to enforce and
during the period a new director joined
us job Callaham director of growth and
economic development so we've added to
the second man this we added a couple of
delegations for her to do with
appearance up business premises and
realizations as I say a full report we
will appear next time it's not been him
tremendously used however that's why I
wish to say thank you any questions
though okay thank you
move to item five the review of the
Constitution now ask the governance
officer nikka cow to do to give us a
report Thank You chair and apologies for
the late circulation of the report to
members for today's meeting so the
report that has been circulated to you
in a supplementary pax is the first of a
series of reports that are presented
throughout the year to the standards
committee this brings suggested
revisions to the Constitution for your
consideration following standards
committee scrutiny of the items
presented you can then make
recommendations on to full council for
adoption it's suggested that this year
we take two sets of revisions to Council
the first one in November 2020 and then
again inmate and t21 referring to the
report at one point two it sets out the
current list of areas identified for
review and then at one point three the
table shows when officers ain't them
forward to you for consideration so this
in turn
of course informs your work plan for the
year ahead you can amend the list at any
time it's a live document so if you have
any suggestions please bring them
forward either in this meeting or at any
time for this meeting in particular we
bring forward two new items for your
consideration the first being the
housing management or terms of reference
and the second one the town fund board
terms of reference which are attached as
Appendix one and two these terms of
reference currently aren't in your
Constitution however we do have good
practice to bring these documents to you
for your awareness and acceptance so if
you wish to suggest any changes these
can be incorporated and any comments you
have become feedback to the officers who
manage these meetings at one point for
width and report it sets out a list of
those items that were taken to the
virtual meeting of annual council and
that went without coming through the
Standards Committee first and these were
made in order so that the council could
operate effectively during the lockdown
period and these are attached as a file
appendix for your consideration your
notice within that that final appendix
there's reference to the ward member
changes at Planning Committee and
there's been some discussion about this
so you'll be aware that the changes
agreed as per the appendix on this
matter were rescinded by delegated
decisions in advance of Planning
Committee yesterday we are proposing
therefore that this this area the
Constitution in particular is brought to
an informal meeting of the planning
committee followed by a special meeting
of the standards committee to discuss
this item specifically around the
September time I think I'm happy to take
any questions chair or assist with any
queries that members may have
any questions Al Jarreau Shipman
it's delicious distinct to counter our
shipment a special meeting about in
September I think that's raised to me a
bigger issue what's happening with how
things are coming through standards and
ending up in full council because
remember rightly the at the point in
which the full council where this was
voted through I mean it's something I
objected to intermediate because there's
things that are be that when they fall
council Belpre trained as though the
full Standards Committee agree to every
single item within that particular
report or whatever it is that comes to
council and that's not the case because
even if you took the last standards
committee and it's not in the minutes
actually which I probably should have
raised it earlier but again had that
meeting I was raised in the problems
with how how things are coming through
and that they either they can have a
massive knock-on effect to the full
council I mean the fact that I mean
David said but in fact that not one
single counselor that was on that
planning committee realizes what the
result of passing that thing was in full
council since such I mean it's a farce
really because how many countless 53
councillors and not one councillor saw
that come in and they're not an
effective but commit and yet people
still voted it through in full council
and until it became the actual plan
committee never woman oh you know we
actually got that massively wrong and
where people realize that if what they
were doing with removing councilors
having a say in the planning committee
for their own ward which I think's a
disaster
well I think it was brought up mainly to
protect counselors but we are going to
review all this as we've already said
under B will be presented in eight
probably in September when everybody has
had a chance if I will look at it and
then we'll bring it to standards and
we'll decide what we're going to do in
the meantime I understand that the
present one has been rescinded so we
reverted back to the old system which
we've already who was implemented
yesterday of planning
could I ask Sarah still to come in on
this please yes thank you
just to confirm that yes the provision
has been suspended until both standards
and planning committee have considered
it so the particular issue that's all I
wish to say however I did wish to give
some comfort in relation to matters
great director council this was at one
off occasion it was because of the
situation we were in the corona virus
the extra work put on us
fact the meetings weren't taking place
at one committees etc it is unlikely to
happen again and the normal situation
which has always been placed previously
will be reverted to the standards
committee these things miss the other
thing to say is about representational
committee thought about any proposal yes
if the Standards Committee those
particular way even if one member votes
against that we always say this was
supported by standards committee because
clearly that was their decision and I
accept there's a point about adding into
the minutes making sure that any
objection or refusal was also booked to
them thank you thank you very much for
that okay Jackie Ridgeway wishes to
speak
oh thank you for that can I just stand
through the chair you said that he was
rescinded for yesterday's meeting but I
beg to differ it wasn't because the
counselor that was actually supposed to
be the voice there wasn't allowed to
actually sit on the bench as a committee
member she could only sit as a member of
the public so I don't think it was
rescinded for yesterday I think it was
and perhaps I can ask Sarah Steinberg to
go through the actual rules as which are
the rules which nothing to do with the
rescinding of this particular item okay
so in relation to the particular
requirement awarded members not to vote
on Planning Committee for the items and
their own ward that was suspended by DD
and is by delegation and is currently
suspended until members of standards in
Planning Committee have considered the
issue that was done in advance of
yesterday's planning committee and I
didn't attend planning committee but I
know that the governance manager was
there maybe she could oh this bit about
what the members thought
yes thank you so counts for Huckabee at
climbing yesterday spoke against an
application and therefore predetermined
herself and therefore she indicated that
she would not be voting on the item such
clear to you I think the chair of
planning has a knife indicated to wish
to speak thank you through the truth
Thank You Nicki I was just going to say
the same issue counselor Huckabee had
already predetermined her objection
before he went into the meeting that's
why she wasn't allowed to vote but she
could have her say break a transmission
server right are there any more
questions on that in Katz there
that's okay counselor off you go brought
this forward and would it help in future
if let's say it's an officer requests
come in to standards or something's one
of the groups or a particular counselor
that wants something changed in the
Constitution well do we actually know
what where those changes are coming from
because I think that potentially makes a
massive difference actually who is the
one that's trying to push this forward
if we actually have that information in
front of us when we're making a decision
to counsel well George go first Nikki I
was given to other members and in one
point three in the table that we have we
say the area of reviewed lead officer
and the date the consideration a simple
remedy to that would be adding an
additional column and then to say we're
at the idea originated if that would
assist okay well I'd like to move on now
to item seven and look at the LGA don't
think we've had a voucher
career ever built on that please could
members please show care that's carried
okay right items sakes gifts
inhospitality review could we have that
about the result of the review please
yeah that's me apologies to members with
the consent of the chair in advance of
the meeting this item has been withdrawn
and will be presented to you at the next
meeting okay thank you for that right
item seven the LGA model code of conduct
consultation because the government's
officer please present this report yes
thank you this is a report to inform the
committee of the Algiers consultation on
the model mode of conduct and to provide
an opportunity for the committee to
raise any comments and that officers can
submit in response to the consultation
the consultation started on the 8th of
June and runs until the 17th of August
the draft model code of conduct is
attached to the report at appendix one
and a comparison with the council's
current code is attached to appendix to
the draft model code does not differ
significantly in content to the local
code already in operation although some
of the language used is different and I
would say it is more succinct I would
draw your attention to the LGA has
drafted the model code
incorporating recommendations from the
Committee on standards in public life
recommendations on local government
ethical standards and if these are
adopted and incorporated it would mean
the code applies to members where they
are acting all claiming or giving the
impression that they are acting in
public or in their capacity as a member
or representative of the council so that
would be a change and a final version of
the model code is expected and sometime
in the autumn and once we have that and
it's been published we will be bringing
this back to the committee we need to
consider whether to adopt the model
I would make changes to the existing
code or something between each other
thank you for that any questions no well
I'll move on to item eight the work
program could the government officers
please present the report this one so
you have your work program which is a
live document it sets out the the plan
to work the forthcoming year you can add
to this and make changes as you see fit
so if members are happy the document
then then the recommendation would be
for acceptance to them okay are there
any questions on the report first
I wish to speak on this chair okay well
could we have a vote on this please
could you please show of a hand in favor
carry chair
thank you item nine an urgent business
I've no urgent items for today's meeting
and that easy to let me know the date of
the next meeting
that's Nicola could tell us when we're
going to have the next meeting Thank You
chair so it's a it's likely the our next
meeting may be a special meeting to
consider the item as we discussed in
regard to the ward councillor voting at
Planning Committee matter we will set up
a date for you and we'll be in contact
with all of you to agree that your next
scheduled meeting will take place on the
30th of September
thank you
and that is it 2 o'clock is it ok well
can I thank the members for their
attendance today now check out some
bridge where he wants to speak
yes go ahead oh thank you and it's just
a point of interest what I'm looking at
on the front sheet that we get my
weights as members of the committee and
we have them in political boxes I always
thought that the standards and planning
wasn't a political group so really I
think you know putting that on the front
of the sheet makes it very political and
as far as I'm concerned it should be
apolitical so I I am asking the
committee if we can just have it where
it just says members of the committee
and everybody's names on the front sheet
without saying what political group
they're in well I'm looking at the
minutes for the 19th of February and
they're all mixed mixed up on that now I
mean on the very front sheet that we get
with the northeast are be sure it's on
the public pack the public document pack
that we can print off and we're upset
which Sarah sends us we have in three
boxes we have the Conservatives Labor
and Liberal Democrats now as I say I
always thought planning and standards
were a political committee and I really
think for it to be an apolitical
committee where we're working across the
board you as a united front then we
should be showing you that we're a
united front and not I put not three
different political parties ok well I
take that on board so if I might yes
we'll make sure that happens for the
next one and afterwards
thank you it's a good point
is that okay for you yeah that's fine
can I also ask that it's done for
planning as well because again it
happens on the planning one and the
planning is again an apolitical
cross-party
committee and I just think you know it
hopefully it just shows that we are
working more in an alliance than
actually is is three different you know
three or four different sort of
political parties certainly my views yes
good we it can we agree on that then
yeah I'm sure that'll be no problem
we'll sort that okay so indicating he
would like to speak
surely we all making a decision on
what's good for instance in Northeast
Asia rather than what a political party
if I might check oh that's a point I
will have a look at the other agendas
but certainly when it comes to council I
think it's necessary to show the
critical groups than that occasion but
I'll look at the others where we think
it's a product that will do the same
thing okay that's okay council Shipman
okay right well if there's no other
matters I will now declare the meeting
is closed
you